what's up guys
bang bang lunch money time well while
she's trying to get rich for us let's
just trying to get our lunch money right
i am here with the beautiful intelligent
plenty by over marinova poppliano
p-i-m-p
pimp looking like miss claws with the
red on today
does miss claus have blonde hair or dark
hair i don't know she has white hair
oh okay cause she's old i get it uh
santa claus by the way i have a
very weird suspicion that he's bald
underneath his
hat so okay don't forget that lunch
money is now sponsored by block five
block five allows you to earn up to
eight point six percent apy in an
interest bearing account
you send them dollars they convert those
dollars to stable coins or to crypto and
they put them in this interest bearing
account
and you can earn up to 8.6 apy go check
it out i use the product i'm an investor
i sit on the board i'm a big fan
and you will be too that's right see
that commercial
you should go check out blockfly.com
pomp just do it because you like us
even if you don't like money just go
check it out block five.com
pom see what it's about check it out
read a little bit
see maybe you get a little tempted you
know hey
are you done yes okay so go check it out
um there is
a second wave of lockdowns that might
occur in new york city
due to the pandemic de blasio was
threatening to shut down zip codes
starting tomorrow certain zip codes that
are seeing
spikes over three percent in a few day
period
now the governor is rejecting that
proposal
saying he'll come up with his own and my
problem is i
am tired of the egos that are constantly
contradicting each other and talking
over each other
at the expense of people's livelihood
well i know what i think what i think
but what do you think or what i think
you think what i think uh i agree with
almost everything that you think the two
things that i will say though
are uh this is dumb
two is we know
that if they do this it will kill
businesses
but hold on before you continue my
problem is
they're killing they're going to kill
businesses in certain
um zip codes and not others and you're
just picking and
it just i don't want to say it but some
of the neighborhoods there's literally
articles being written
there's there's specific religious
groups that are in some of those zip
codes
yeah there's a big argument this here's
what we're gonna about to play out ready
this is exactly what happened when cuomo
was yelling and screaming pounding his
chest saying everyone deserves to be
able to go into uh the elderly
uh homes right i don't care you have to
let them in it's all about equality
and you know what happened he got
thousands of people killed
thousands of people killed on that
decision new york city
elderly care saw this thing ravaged okay
what does that have to do with it
because everyone thinks about it as like
oh the government officials decisions
has no downside right they can only make
it
thinks that nobody thinks that no uh
people when they think of these
lockdowns what they just think of is
like what's the worst that like
can happen like sending the people into
lockdown like sure maybe we don't need
to do it or maybe we do
but like what's the downside to it but
what they don't realize is
there's the economic impact and also
there is a
spike in suicides and alcoholism like in
all these things
when we've done this right there's
literally counties around the world that
are now reporting data
around all this stuff and so what i find
very hypocritical is twofold one
they want small businesses to shut down
but they're still taking their salary
why has andrew cuomo or bill de blasio
not said if i ask
that my constituents to give up their
livelihood i won't take my salary until
i opened has anybody
ever done that any politician well
multiple presidents have said hey i'll
just i'll
like donate i think trump did it i think
i think obama did it maybe
i think bush did it so like it's popular
at like that level i don't think that
we've seen governors or mayors in this
environment do that
but that's the first thing wait a second
you're telling these people to shut
their business down why don't you shut
your income off
right that's a second thing is
they were encouraging thousands tens of
thousands of people to go into the
street
in the middle of coronavirus and they
said it as
their social causes there's all this
stuff right again i'm not here to debate
that that's fine you want to go on the
street
great right and there were some very
worthy causes as to why people
wanted to go protest and do all that
stuff but you then can't hypocritically
say
we're going to allow that to happen but
we're not going to allow you to do
outdoor dining at your restaurant
where is the balance what what is the
science behind allowing one and not the
other
and so i think it's just a very slippery
slope and what we need to remember
is that the mayor and the governor they
have no clue they know
just as much about coronavirus as me
polina and you watching this
we all have the same data so again
we just don't know all the information
and therefore playing this game of
i'm the almighty i'm going to pick and
choose what zip codes are going to shut
down all this stuff
it's all nonsense it's all political
theater and
what i think is going to end up playing
out is we're going to look back on this
and say that this entire thing was
completely mismanaged by politicians
and it was all political or managed crap
across the spectrum across parties like
this is all nonsense next
that's my rant for the day all right
you're not allowed any more rants
because we have 20 minutes left
chamath polypetia has found his next
spac
target clover health a medicare
insurance startup
startup startup backed by alphabet
clover will go public via merger with
social capital
capital hedo sofia holdings i can't talk
to
i think you're doing it the deal values
clover at 3.7 billion it includes up to
1.2 billion dollars in cash
so chamath is going all in yeah
chamoth is executing like a absolute
animal right now i love it
i love watching so why did it take this
long for spax to catch up because i
literally remember writing about this in
2018 when he first started his pack
so spax are a popular thing that's been
going on but it usually has happened in
like
the tsx the toronto stock exchange like
other places and they've always kind of
been this like
in a very over generalized manner before
we get upset they've always been like
this mechanism that people used
that maybe weren't like the top
investors
or the top companies use these right uh
and a lot of times they're also referred
to as like reverse takeovers oh i see
and so uh all of a sudden shemoth did
the big one the first one
ipoa and that's when he did virgin
galactic and i think everyone was like
whoa but it took him a while to do
virgin galactic it took him like
you have two years once you raise the
capital give two years to go find a deal
and so once he got that one lined up and
he did it everyone was like
oh my god this is like look at what he
just did
and then it was like ipob ipoc great
little tidbit for you
he's already reserved ticker's ipo a
through ipo z
so all 26 letters of the alphabet he has
the ticker's ipo there's a lot more
specs coming guys
potentially um this is a great one
though he he's basically got the same
thought process of a lot of other
investors which is
a post-pandemic world healthcare's going
to take off american healthcare is
actually really bad there hasn't been a
lot of innovation and needs to be
solved yeah i agree very expensive
in this country it is very expensive
next all right
well here's what i want to talk about
nobel prize
in physics awarded to three scientists
for work on black holes
we should be paying these people not
do you think that a black hole could
like
swallow the earth well
if you would read the work of these
three nobel science scientists you would
know
i'm gonna read this later today actually
yeah be a black hole expert by tomorrow
so uh what did they find um hold on
they got half of the 1.1 i know it's
really sad
um oh god why are they not telling us
what it's doing
okay they were recognized for their work
on the gateways to eternity
known as black holes massive objects
that swallow light
and everything else forever that falls
in their unsparing
malls whoa they basically prove that
black holes must exist if albert
einstein's theory of gravity known as
general relativity is right the second
half was split
the second half of the 1.1 million
dollar prize was split between two other
uh folks for the relentless and
decades-long investigation of the dark
monster here in the center of our own
galaxy
uh gathering evidence to convict it of
the supermassive black hole there's a
typo in that bluebird article um
black holes are real aliens are real
hold on hold on
ufos are real i'm sure you go down that
don't you think that we should be
paying these people more than 1.1
million for well that's the prize that
they all said oh they all split it yeah
they got a couple hundred thousand
dollars and then after taxes they only
got a hundred
percent that's what we wanted why look
at the work they're doing how much is
cuomo getting
ah see this is the this is the challenge
with uh
capitalism or or the uh the beauty of
capitalism
they're not producing any economic
output
they're producing ideas but the whole
point of
the value that you capture is the value
that you create so what's the economic
value i'm sure over time there will be
economic value based on these findings
but you're not encouraging
people to do important work by not
incentivizing them with
monetary reward so counter argument
which you don't have to agree with am i
going to get pissed at you
no take elon musk who has created
enormous
economic value and is worth 70 billion
dollars
right there's a reason there's only one
of him agreed
but these scientists who i agree that
they should get paid more money
but i'm just explaining why
scientists don't get paid that much
money is because they don't create
businesses that create enterprise value
or economic value
thank god for american football players
who create so much economic value
they literally create billions i
understand but it's stupid
again we oh we can argue whether it's
stupid or not i'm not disagreeing with
that
but what i do think it ends up being
interesting is
uh that we need to get scientists more
programs right because
because that's the challenge what you do
is you end up getting the government
to say hey we're gonna foot the bill
right which a lot of people will
disagree with but if that's what you
want to do
then the government should simply say
hey we're going to fund all this stuff
right and that's where the economic
value comes from
polina is not happy with the scientist
situation today it's all right
i have my opinion you have yours we can
move on all right let's go
john mcafee indicted for tax evasion and
arrested in spain
he's the anti-virus software magnate and
former libertarian presidential
candidate
he's been indicted for tax evasion he
allegedly failed to file his taxes for
four years despite earning millions in
income
economic output between 2014 and 2018
from promoting cryptocurrencies
consulting work speaking engagements and
selling the rights to his life story for
a documentary
what is he doing in spain doesn't he
know that if you go somewhere else
they'll
catch you i don't know
i've met john mcafee i interviewed him
for the podcast
in person the guy is the guy
what you see on the internet is what you
see in person
on a trip i was not allowed to attend no
i did not want to attend it look
the facts will come out this is why in
america you're presumed innocent until
proven guilty
we'll see what happens i i don't really
i feel like i don't have any information
to uh other than what i read well he
didn't pay his taxes and
he was very vocal allegedly he was vocal
about it he was living in the bahamas
see but he allegedly didn't pay taxes
but if
i think what i read in the filing is
that he didn't actually
take the money like he didn't get paid
the money he said like had it sent to a
bank account and it was somebody else's
banking
like it's all his complexity to it again
what they're alleging could be true or
could not
i i just don't know all right what's
next all right let's see what hot tate
you have on this now
that's not a hot take batman has been
postponed until 2022
um because you know after more than 500
cineworld theaters are closed and
yeah it's not going to be happening
sales are down
no point in launching this thing if no
one's going to be there to pay
22 is a long time guys yeah well they're
probably just making sure that they're
gonna for sure have everything back to
normal
they should just do like a a release
online but the releases online that
people have tried haven't gone so well
wait why because uh
it's hard like it's hard to corral
people yeah and it's just like i could
do all this other why
am i gonna pay for batman when i could
just use my netflix like i watch
something else right
like it's like a whole thing so i would
i would watch batman
i i would too but it's just like they
can't get the same amount of money they
can get at the box office so they might
as well wait
okay hot cake um
so frozen trash cans for the people who
do not take out the trash immediately
and it smells
um there are now frozen trash cans
it's called petal you know that company
uh it's created a next generation trash
can that arrives in a person-sized
box and it's a narrow trash can that
freezes your trash
so you can toss in anything smelly and
enjoy an
infinite amount of time until you can
take out the garbage
or alternatively you could just take out
the garbage
facts it's not very sustainable so it's
not great but
if you have diapers compost dog stuff
sanitary products we should get this why
do we need that
we don't produce that much trash but we
produce lots of economic value there
folks
all right let's do the joke
i don't want you to hear my joke now
it's not going to be funny so i'm not
going to miss anything
all right come on hurry because i have
to do a call in two minutes
oh let me take my time there is a fine
line between a numerator
and a denominator
okay okay but only a fraction of people
understand this
[Music]
all right today's wasn't very good can i
get my immature jokes back soon
you guys don't know there was a there
was a controversy that told me i can't
do a mature joke wait why
no i didn't when did i say that immature
jokes will be back tomorrow it's on
record alright guys that's it for lunch
money today
we'll talk to you tomorrow bang bang
hope you guys enjoyed this episode of
lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five so go check them
out there's a link in the description
that you can click on
i'm an investor a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
black lives my second favorite thing in
the world behind polena they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to eight point six percent
interest on an interest bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to 8.6 interest on a deposit in an
interest bearing account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends